john mcdonnell at john's is live on the
program mr mcdonald it has been a while
so i do hope you're well
very well very well good to speak to you
again
so let's talk at spring's statement if
you have a crystal ball in front of you
you may well consult it but also you
might have a wish list what do you want
to see from the chancellor today
could i just address mark harper's point
because i think he's made a valid point
i
i'm not i would like the national
insurance
rise scrapped but you have to say where
else you could find the money for the
nhs and social care and a number of
think tanks including the tuc did
recommend to the chancellor at the time
what you can do is basically
tax wealth at the same rate as your
taxing income so in other words tax
capital gains tax at the same rate as
income tax and that would bring in the
estimate 17 billion so actually it would
be ideally suited to cover the amount
that the chancellor would want to raise
that's just as an aside because i
thought it was important that mark made
that point that if you are going to
scrap something you've got to replace it
with something else and i this could be
the way in which you have a fairer
taxation system well the first step
towards anyway
i think the most important thing for me
is you've got to protect people you've
got to inflation proof first of all
those people are going to be hit the
hardest in this coming months and their
people on pensions and benefits but also
the low paid as well and therefore
you've got to inflation proof
increases in pay as well that's the
first thing the second
i do think it is about controlling
prices i think we need to make sure that
we're capping the profits made by the
energy companies we saw the figures from
the think tank commonwealth that
identified the profit rates of some of
the energy companies as 42 45
in addition to that i think we need to
look at other prices that we have to
control
the mayor for london sadiq khan has said
let's have a rent freeze i called for
that last year i think rent controls are
part of it and andy burnham up in
manchester making sure now he has
control over buses we make sure that we
prevent fare increases as well so
packages like that where we protect
people's incomes inflation-proof them
then also reduce an element of the costs
that are falling upon them i think is
absolutely key the other issue for me as
well and
i do criticize the government for this
over a long period of time that we need
to go for green growth and the first
step on green growth in the way in which
we can help people with their energy
bills is insulation we've been calling
for this for over a decade and if we
could have
capital investment in insulation
programs now it would increase the
number of jobs that we got the
predictions by about 450 000
it would insulate people's homes and
reduce their energy bills i think that's
the sort of package i'd like to see
today and i think we've got to recognize
how tough it is for people out there
therefore they need assistance now sure
i i i think both you and i would agree
that uh if if much if any of that gets
into the chancellor's statement today
you'll be a lucky man mr mcdonald but
but i wonder what your view is
of borrowing right now i mean you and i
spoke an awful lot back when you were
shadow chancellor and you often got
criticized with that phrase you know the
magic money tree you know given what we
have seen over the past couple of years
in terms of borrowing i wonder whether
you somewhat feel that your stance
has been vindicated
well it has but you know
i told you so isn't it a particularly
good phrase to be honest i want to look
to the future
i think what we've got to do is make
sure that we're responsible in
everything that we do and the
responsible way forward is to recognize
that in times like this
there's real hardship out there people
are suffering we're talking about people
it is true people choosing between
heating and eating we're talking about
people who've had their wages virtually
frozen for nearly 12 years it's tough
out there so yes we've got to protect
people in this short term and that does
mean an increase in borrowing in the
short term but the most important thing
is i said time and time again in our
interviews you borrow to invest
and that's why investment in alternative
energy sources in insulating our homes
is the right thing to do at the moment
because you'll reap such huge rewards
and actually in terms of energy and
alternative energy sources and
insulation you'll reap them pretty quick
as well
sure mr mcdonald
given given our previous conversations
you might not be happy about this but we
whenever we have talked we've always
ended up talking about what's going on
within within the labour party and so it
is again today recent recently of course
you did pull out of the stop the war
rally after pressure from the leader's
office because of their stance over you
know the extent to which nato is
responsible responsible for for what is
going on in ukraine
were you entirely happy to withdraw from
that event and genuinely what is your
view of the extent to which nato is
responsible uh from the world's position
for what we're seeing i i would drive my
name for the statement and withdraw
because the the leader of the labour
party said so
and i because also the statement was out
of date and the i said then you know
we're in a war situation what we don't
want is internal political debates and
discussions like that and it would be a
complete distraction from the focus that
we should have on securing peace we've
got time to debate the issues around
nato and russia and the long term
what we've got to do now everything
every word we use now has got to be
about securing peace and we shouldn't be
distracted from that we too many people
are suffering at the moment so that was
my focus then it's my focus now and
remember
people seem to forget i was one of the
people who helped set up the ukraine
solidarity campaign over 10 or 11 years
ago we were campaigning with ukrainian
trade unions and others trying to secure
the long-term democratic future of the
ukraine i think that's the issue for me
now and i think there will be a time
when we debate the security system for
the whole of europe in the future what
will reassure people what will give us
peace now i think the focus has got to
be on securing peace yeah unfortunately
we are out of time so we can't even
debate it here john mcdonnell good to
have you on the programme once again do
take care
thank you